Hallo, mein Name ist Topgös, ich bin hier als Assistent, und ich bin heute für Sie zuständig.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen das Anamnese-Gespräch führen, aber ich muss zu Ihnen
Ich muss zu Ihnen zu persönlichen Daten angefragen stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Hanelore Lindemann.
Hanelore ist eine Frau.
Frau Lindemann, könntest du bitte vor und nach Namen genau und langsam abstabieren?
Hanelore, ich stabe Ha, A, N, N, E, L, O, R, E.
Hanelore.
Und nach Namen bitte?
Lin-demann, L, I, N, D, E, M, A, N, N.
Anne Lindemann.
Okay, Frau Lindemann, vielen Dank. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau gebaut?
Am 1. Mai 1966.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,60 m groß und wiege zur Zeit 68 kg.
Okay, Frau Lindemann, was führt Sie zu uns? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe seit 3 Stunden ziemlich stark Schmerzen im linken Arm.
Das geht bis in die Finger, besonders der Daumen-Schmerz und auch der Zeigefinger.
Aber der gesamte Arm geht mehr in den Daumenbereich.
Das habe ich seit 3 Stunden.
Wie schreibst du Ihre Schmerzen?
Sind Sie eher dumpf oder drücken oder stechen?
Es ist mehr als so ein dumpfer Schmerz.
Teilweise ist auch etwas kribbeln, wie ein kribbeln in den Arm und in den Fingern.
Haben Sie Schmerzen in den Brustbereich, Brustkopf?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 0 bis 10?
0, den kleinen Schmerzen, 10, den sehr starken Schmerzen bedeutet.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Ich höre gar nicht.
Ich würde sagen 5 bis 6.
5 bis 6?
Ich höre gar nicht.
Frau Lindemann, hätten Sie früher ein bisschen mehr Schmerzen?
Die Verbindung ist schlecht.
5 bis 6?
Ich höre gar nicht.
Hatten Sie früher ein bisschen mehr Schmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Erstes Mal.
Frau Lindemann, ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, mir ist nicht schwindelig.
Haben Sie Fibbe?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Haben Sie in der Zeit Abgenonung oder Südgenonung?
Nein, Gewicht ist immer gleichgeblieben.
Gut.
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Nackenschmerzen?
Ja, etwas.
Wenn ich den Kopf drehe zur rechten Seite, dann habe ich Schmerzen im Nacken
und dann ist auch das Schmerz und das Kribbeln im Arm schlimmer.
Es ist stärker.
Welche Seite, wenn Sie Ihren Kopf drehen?
Wenn ich den Kopf nach rechts drehe.
Nach rechts.
Aber Sie haben linke Arme.
Ja, linke Arme.
Okay, verstehe Frau Lindemann.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es daran gelegen hat.
Ich habe versucht, zu Hause Gardinen, eine Gardiner aufzuhängen,
oben an der Decke, eine Gardiner am Fenster.
Da musste ich den Kopf immer hochheben, so hochgrecken.
Und danach fingen die Schmerzen an.
Okay, verstehe.
Können Sie mich verstehen?
Ja, verstehe Sie.
Ich höre Sie.
Manchmal weg, manchmal komm, aber kein Problem.
Was ist von Beruf Frau Lindemann?
Arbeit in einer Kita, Kindertagesstätte.
Okay, haben Sie Stress in Arbeit?
Nein, es ist eine anstrengende Arbeit, aber die macht mir Spaß.
Es ist gut.
Sie haben ein Garten und arbeiten Sie schon im Garten?
Ja, ich habe heute Morgen eine Gardiner aufgehängt am Fenster.
Wenn Sie hochheben könnten, schmerzen.
Danach sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten, glaube ich, als Ursache.
Ja, als Ursache.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung.
Ich habe vor einem Jahr eine Darmspiegelung machen lassen.
Eine Vorsorgendarmspiegelung, die beiden Ordnung.
Wasserlassen habe ich etwas Probleme beim Husten.
Wenn ich Husten muss und ließen muss, dann habe ich manchmal, geht etwas Urin ab.
Da sagt die Frau, das hängt damit zusammen mit meinen Geburt.
Ich habe drei Kinder geboren und da ist mein Schließmuskel nicht mehr so richtig gut.
Okay, ich bin ein Kindertag.
Sind Sie von Haarat?
Ja.
Und sind Sie mit der Irene Familie zusammen?
Mit meiner Mann.
Die Kinder sind schon aus dem Haus, hier sind ja schon älter.
Okay.
Rachen Sie frahin Dama?
Nein, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Früher haben sie da vorne.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke etwas Wein, 1-2 Gläser pro Woche.
Nicht jeden Tag.
Okay.
Super.
Nehmen Sie bitte nicht persönlich, ich muss diese Fragen stellen.
Nehmen Sie Droge?
Nein.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch frahin Dama?
Mein Vater ist verstorben.
Im Alter von 68 Jahren ist er verstorben an einem Herzinfarkt.
Oh, ist es mühsalat?
Und der ist 86 Jahre alt.
Die Mutter hat eine Herzmuskelschwäche.
Und hat Nieren-Schwäche.
Die Nieren funktionieren nicht mehr so gut.
Ja.
Okay.
Es ist mühsalat.
Und haben Sie hier Schwester?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Die Schwester ist 56 Jahre alt und hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Okay, Frau Lindermann, haben Sie vor Erkrankungen Bluthochdruck
oder Blutdruck?
Ja, ich habe einen Blutdruck.
Ich habe einen Blutdruck.
Nehmen Sie dagegen etwas?
Ja, dagegen nehme ich etwas ein.
Das Mitte, das heißt, Biso pro Yol.
Wie viel Milligramm nehmen Sie?
Hinterstit 5.
Einmal täglich?
Einmal morgens und einmal abends.
Und dann nehme ich noch Kanndesartan,
auch einmal morgens und einmal abends.
Okay.
Haben Sie die andere Krankheit?
andere Krankheiten.
Ja, ich habe seit vier Jahren habe ich Zucker.
Okay.
Typ 2, alte Zucker oder?
Alter, alte Zucker.
Da muss ich auch eine Tablette nehmen.
Was nehmen Sie?
Medformin?
Ja, Medformin, das ist 850.
Dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette und abends halbe.
Und dann nehme ich noch,
eben hohes Cholesterin auch seit vier Jahren.
Nehmen Sie, das Mittel heißt,
Rosu-Vastatin.
Da steht 20 hinter.
Und dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette ein.
Dann nehme ich auch noch ein Medikament wegen meinem Herzen.
Da nehme ich ASS 100.
Eine Tablette,
weil ich hatte vor zwei Jahren,
vor einem Jahr hatte ich eine Herzkatheter-Untersuchung
und habe dabei so zwei so kleine Röhrchen,
die die Herzkranzgefäße eingesetzt bekommen.
Weil meine Herzkranzgefäße verengt waren.
Okay.
Frau Lindemann,
haben Sie schon in der
wichtigsten drei Krankheiten,
haben Sie schon ihre Blutdruck regelmäßig gemessen
oder Blutzucker?
Blutdruck,
regelmäßig,
den Blutzucker,
da bin ich etwas unzuverlässig.
Manchmal melde ich mit dem Blutzucker
ein Blutzucker, der meines Mannes,
weil der hat auch Zucker
und der nicht das regt.
Da bin ich etwas faul.
Der Blutzucker war zu letzt 140 auf 90.
Das war vor drei Tagen.
Aber gehen Sie manchmal wegen Blutzucker
Ihren Hausarzt-Päleit?
Ja, ich gehe alle drei Monate zum Hausarzt
wegen dem Zucker.
Wir haben Blut bekommen und der Zucker
langzeitwert gemessen.
Und das war der Arzt zufrieden.
Super.
Okay.
Geniokologie.
Genzi,
regelmäßig Ihren Fraunarzt-Kontrolle Ihrenzi.
Ich habe eine Fraunärztin gegen ich regelmäßig zur Vorsorge.
Das war das letzte Mal, glaube ich,
im November, letzten November.
Aber das war die zweite Woche.
Super.
Und wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Ja, die ist sehr unregelmäßig geworden.
Das ist nur noch sehr wenig, sehr selten.
Also, bestimmt seit ein, zwei Jahren
ist die Periode sehr unregelmäßig.
Wir haben nicht eine Periode für die Regulation.
Ja.
Das ist unregelmäßig.
Periode ist ein
Schmanger. Nein. Nein.
Sind Sie 48 oder 40 Jahre?
50.
Okay.
Okay, Fralindaman.
Mhm.
Aber sie hat gesagt, ich könnte
zusammenfassen, Fralindaman.
Ja, ja.
Sie haben seit drei Stunden
linke Arme und Finger daumenschmerzen.
Sie schmerzen dumfe.
Sie haben Kribbeln.
Sie...
die ihre Schmerzen,
ihre Kopfrechte Seite, wenn sie rechte Seite drehen,
dann verschlechtert sie sich.
Ja, sie haben keine...
Sie haben keine Schwindel, keine Übel, keine Fieber,
keine Gewissverlust.
Aber wenn sie ihre Arme
haben, die Schmerzen anfangen,
sie denken.
Okay.
Sie ist erster.
Sie hat nicht raucheren,
regelmäßig weniger trinken Alkohol.
Aber sie haben drei verschiedene Krankheiten,
wichtige Krankheiten.
Noch ein paar Punkte.
Ja, möchten Sie etwas zu viel?
Ja, also ich glaube,
dass der Schmerz entstanden ist,
weil ich meinen Kopf so lange
nach oben zur Decke gestreckt habe
beim Aufhängen der Gardinen.
Ist meine Erklärung für den Schmerz.
Da ist irgendwas passiert im Hals
oder wo ich weiß es nicht genau.
Das kann sein.
Okay.
Sonst haben Sie das alles richtig widergegeben.
Okay, Frau Lindemann,
vielen Dank für die ausführliche Informationen.
Ich habe wichtige Informationen gesammelt.
Okay.
Wollen Sie Fragen?
Was kann ich haben?
Was kann das sein?
Ja, Frau Lindemann,
ich möchte nichts zu sagen,
aber ich kann nichts zu sagen.
Vielleicht kann es ein
Sie haben die wichtige Hypertension,
die
Röntgen, Nacken, Schmerzen.
Gut, dann versuchen Sie das für sich zusammenzufassen in medizinische
Fachausdrücke, die Beschwerden, die Schmerzen, Ausstrahlung,
was auch immer.
Wir klären noch im Kollegen- und Kolleginnenkreis,
ob bestimmte Dinge vielleicht noch ergänzt werden sollen
oder ob noch Fragen sind.
Wir haben Kollegen und Kolleginnen noch eine Frage,
wie wir das gesagt haben.
Ich habe eine Frage für Sie, Frau Lindewan.
Haben Sie Kraftfellows in Ihrer betroffenen Arme?
Können Sie es benutzen?
Wenn ich die linke Hand zumache, die Faustbale,
das ist etwas weniger, habe ich den Eindruck.
Etwas weniger Kraft als normal.
Danke Ihnen für die Antwort.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wo sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Oberarm, Unterarm oder ganz Arm?
Können Sie beschreiben?
Einmal etwas Schmerzen oben im Hals.
Oberarm im Hals?
Einmal etwas Schmerzen, aber stärkere Schmerzen
ist im Arm, mehr im Unterarm
und auf der Seite, wo der Daumen ist.
Können wir sagen,
von Nacken bis Zeigefinger?
Bis in den Daumen und Zeigefinger,
ausdrehen, aber besonders im Unterarm
und in der Hand.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Bewegungseinchränkungen?
Wenn ich den Kopf drehe, besonders nach rechts,
da merke ich, dass der Schmerz sich verstärkt
und dass das Kribbeln stärker wird.
Am Eisen laufen, dieses pelzige Gefühl.
Eine Frage, Frau Lindemann.
Ist Ihnen Muskelkraft oder Muskelverhältung
im Nackenbereich aufgefallen?
Normalerweise nicht.
Aber es fühlt sich etwas komisch an den Nacken,
etwas eigenartig und wie gesagt,
es ist auch etwas schmerzhaft.
Ich glaube schon, dass der Muskel etwas verspannt ist.
Eine Frage.
Schlägt Ihr Herz ungewöhnlich, langsam oder schneller?
Frau Lindemann.
Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Das Herz war eigentlich, da gab es noch nie Probleme.
Ich bin ja auch in Kontrolle beim Kardiologen
wegen dem Herzkarteter und wegen dieser Röhrchen,
den Herz ganz gefessen.
Aber bisher ist mir der Herzrhythmus noch nie aufgefallen,
dass er zu schnell, zu langsam oder unregelig schlürt.
Danke schön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie etwas Schweres gehoben
oder haben Sie eine bewegende Bewegung gemacht?
Vor den Schmerzen?
Ja, plötzlich nicht.
Aber ich habe eben einige Zeit versucht,
eine Gardine aufzuhängen,
am Fenster zu Hause.
Ich habe eine Gardine.
Ich habe sie immer so hochheben.
Das war vielleicht, das hat er zum Beigetragen, glaube ich.
Haben Sie Taubhaut?
Ja, ein bisschen fälziges Gefühl.
Also so wie Kribbeln.
Das ist vielleicht auch etwas taub.
Danke.
Eine Frage würde ich ergänzen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit einen Unfall gehabt,
einen Sturz gehabt oder einen Autounfall?
Man nennt das ja eine Peitschenverletzung
der Herzwebel-Säule.
Eine Distortion habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ein Unfall.
Die andere Frage ist, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja.
Die anderen ist bisher nicht gefordert.
Am Ende alle Fragen stellen.
Alle Sturz und Verträglichkeiten sind nicht gefragt.
Die Impfung geht nicht gefragt.
Dauernd nicht gut.
Ich habe Sie gegen...
Also Unverträglichkeiten, Allergien habe ich nicht.
Mein Hausarzt sagt, ich bin ausreichend geimpft zur Zeit.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Muss ich auch als Erzieherin in der Kita?
Da muss ich immer aktuell geimpft sein.
Sonst darf ich da nicht arbeiten.
Ich war im letzten Jahr nicht in Ausland verreist.
Ich war immer nur in Deutschland.
Ich bin als Kind am Blinddarm operiert worden.
Ich bin als Kind am Leistenbruch operiert worden.
Vor zehn Jahren hatte ich eine Geilenblasenoperation.
Wegen Geilensteinen hatte ich auch Kohleken.
Ich hatte drei Operationen.
Haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen eine Geilenblasenoperation?
Nein, habe ich bisher nicht gemacht.
Sie haben gesagt, ich würde gerne wissen,
ob die Schmerzen auch genau beschreiben.
Ich habe die Schmerzen einmal im Nacken, im Halsbereich.
Aber die sind nicht so stark im Halsbereich.
Stärker sind sie im Arm.
Besonders im Unterarm und im Daumen und im Zeigefinger.
Da habe ich Schmerzen und da kribbelt es auch sehr stark.
Da habe ich ein bisschen...
Da merke ich auch, dass ich nicht so gut zufassen kann.
Aber sind die Schmerzen da?
Die Schmerzen sind aber da seit drei Stunden.
Und mit der Zeit verschlechtert hätten sich die Schmerzen?
Um den Kopf nach rechts drehen, habe ich den Eindruck,
der Schmerz und das Kribbeln wird schlimmer.
Ich denke, die Fragen gestellt, Herr Oberast.
Können wir erst als Gespräche anfangen?
Gerne, gerne anfangen.
Hallo, schönen guten Tag, Herr Oberast.
Haben Sie gerade Zeit für mich?
Wir haben eine neue Patientin.
Sie heißt Frau Hanelore Lindemann.
Die Frau Lindemann stelle sich bei uns
wegen drei Stunden
starker Arme schmerzen.
Vor die Schmerzen strahlen, nacken aus.
Auch daumenfinger aus.
Außerdem berichtete die Patientin,
die Schmerzen...
die Schmerzen, wenn sie Kopf drehen,
wenn sie Kopf drehen, die Schmerzen per Steg sein.
Sie haben keine...
Ich möchte einmal kurz unterbrechen.
Wie alt ist Frau Lindemann?
Sie ist 58 Jahre alt, jahre Patientin.
Ich wiederhole mal, was Sie mir jetzt berichtet haben.
Sie sind entschuldigend.
Sie ist 1. Mai 1966 geboren.
Sie ist 1 Meter 60 groß, 78 Kilogramm schwer.
68 Kilogramm.
68, 78.
Ich wiederhole einmal, was Sie mir gesagt haben.
Frau Hanelore Lindemann, jetzt haben wir ergänzt,
eine 58-jährige Patientin,
die uns in der Notaufnahme vor.
Sie berichtet über seit 3 Stunden bestehender Schmerzen
im Bereich der Halswirbelsäule und des linken Armes,
besonders stark im Bereich des linken Unterarmes.
Und welcher Finger?
Welchen Finger ist der Schmerz besonders?
Daumen.
Das ist ein dummer Schmerz mit kribbeln Parästisien.
Wie stark ist der Schmerzgrad?
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 bis 6 auf der NRS Schmerzskala.
Gut, prima. Gibt es einen Auslöser, eine Ursache für diese Schmerzen?
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, wenn Sie Ihren Armen hochheben,
und schwer heben, könnte die Schmerzen aufgetreten sein.
Was hat die Patientin vorher, in der Zeit vorher gemacht?
Sie haben eine Blume.
Eine Gardine ist ein Vorhang vor dem Fenster.
Sie haben dort einen blauen Vorhang.
Schauen Sie mal auf Ihre rechte Seite.
Sie haben eine Gardine.
Sie haben eine Gardine, die oben versucht aufzuhängen.
Nicht Blume, Gardine.
Das kann die Ursache eventuell sein.
Hat die Patientin einen Unfall vorher gehabt?
Nein, Sie haben nicht einen Unfall gehabt,
sondern die Schmerzen, die hochheben.
Vielleicht eine Muskelschmerz.
Hat die Patientin chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, Sie haben 3 wichtige chronische Erkrankungen.
Arterielle Hypertonie, Diabetes mellitus 2 und Hypercholestrinie.
Sie haben 2 Stands.
Was war das mit Instanz?
Hartz-Katheter.
Wann war es?
Ich weiß nicht.
Vor 2 Jahren?
Nein, im Jahr.
Es findet sich eine arterielle Hypertonie seit 5 Jahren.
Sie hat 4 Jahre mit 2 Stands.
Sie hat eine Hypercholesterinie seit 4 Jahren.
Sie wurde schon operiert.
Ich habe nicht die erste Operation gehört.
Ich habe nur einen Leistungsbruch gehört.
Als Kind war sie.
Kennen Sie das Medizinischen Begriff?
Ja, Leistungsbruch.
Ich habe nicht die erste Operation gehört.
Sie hat eine Hypertomie.
Kolesistektomie, fürst ein Yarin.
Sehr gut.
Bordesi Kolesistektomie.
Und in der Kindheit eine Appendektomie und eine...
Güntherne.
Sehr gut.
Gut.
Gibt es andere Risikofaktoren bei der Patientin?
Ja, die ist erst jahr.
Vielleicht muss die Kinder manchmal umarmen und heben.
Okay.
Was hat die Patientin, raucht die Patientin?
Nein, sie... sie nicht rauchern.
Okay.
Und nicht so viel trinken, Alkohol.
Und die Familienamnese ist dort etwas Erwähnenswertes?
Ja, sie haben drei Kinder und wohnt mit ihrem Mann zusammen.
Und sie haben kein Stress in Arbeitsplätzen.
Und aber sie haben im Wechseljahr vielleicht, nachtemstens vielleicht,
Menoposer vielleicht.
Eltern leben die Eltern noch?
Ja, nein, sie haben schon gestorben.
Und welche Alter, wie alt der Vater da war?
68 Jahre alt, weil er gestorben.
Und Mutter, 86.
Die Mutter lebt noch?
Lebt noch und nirgendwo versagt.
Sie können den medizinischen Begriff nennen?
Ja, Coronar, Herzkrankheit oder?
Herzmuskelschwäche, nicht?
Herzmuskel, ja, Herzmuskelschwäche, Corona.
Hat ihr Mediapartin?
Nein.
Nein, das ist jetzt die Hygieneinsuffizienz.
Hygieneinsuffizienz, Cardiomyopathie kann auch in eine Myocardinsuffizienz nennen,
aber das ist noch etwas anderes.
Also sie hat eine Myocardinsuffizienz.
Und ich habe gesagt, die Mutter hat eine Nieren-Schwäche.
Also sie wahrscheinlich einen Kreatininwert von, sagen wir, 2,5.
Ha, Nieren, nicht Nierenversagen, Nieren-Schwäche.
Niereninsuffizienz.
Wahrscheinlich hat sie eine noch konsierte Niereninsuffizienz, das wissen wir nicht genau,
aber kein Nierenversagen, dann wäre sie wahrscheinlich dialysepflichtig.
Ja, okay.
Niereninsuffizienz ist das in Ordnung, Niereninsuffizienz.
Ich würde ruhig sagen, Niereninsuffizienz ist durchaus ein medizinischer Fachbegriff in Deutschland.
Niereninsuffizienz.
Vielleicht rennale Insuffizienz, aber der Begriff Niereninsuffizienz ist eigentlich gebräuchlich.
Ja, gut.
Gut, hat die Patientin Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Keine Probleme.
Sie hat gesagt, nur Urin-Probleme.
Sie haben drei Kinder bekommen, deswegen,
wenn sie Husten haben, könnte unwillig Urin-Harn blasen.
Das geht Urin ab.
Wir nennen das eher, sie klagt über eine Stressincontinens.
Nein, Stressincontinens, ja.
Wenn Blachen, Niesen oder Pressen, also Bauchmuskeln,
anspannen kann zu einer Stressincontinens.
Stressincontinens, aber nicht diese Schmerzen erklären.
Ja, der Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung.
Die Patientin hat berichtet, dass sie vor einiger Zeit eine Untersuchung hatte für den Damen.
Ja, die Koloskopie war gut.
Genau, sie hatte eine Vorsorge-Koloskopie und die war in Ordnung.
Ja, gut.
Kein Problem.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
HVC-Centrum, oder?
Ja.
Da unten steht schon eine Diagnose.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Aber ich ...
Diskus pro Lassus.
Akute Diagnose, würde ich jetzt erst mal sagen,
Servico brachiali, also ausgehend wahrscheinlich von der HWS.
Vielleicht ein Diskusprolaps, ja, kann gut sein.
Und dieser Diskusprolaps strahlt in das Segment C6, C7 ein.
Daumen, Zeigefinger, das ist ja mehr C6, 7.
Kleinfingerseitig wäre wahrscheinlich C8.
Alle Orthopädenneurologen unter Ihnen oder Neurochirurgen sollen mich korrigieren,
wenn das falsch ist.
Aber ich würde sagen, C6, 7.
Segment wahrscheinlich betroffen in der Halswirbelsäule.
Der Auslöser ist eventuell diese lange Haltung, die die Patientin hatte.
Sie wollte die Gardiner auffängen, der Kopf war verdreht,
eine Rotation abgeknickt, dann kann das passieren.
Aber vielleicht war dort auch eine Vorschädigung.
Differenzialdiagnose?
Als Differenzialdiagnose ein Diskusprolapsus,
Akutes Coronasendrom,
vertigo, vielleicht vertigo, aber
und unkontrolliert Diabetes mellitus.
Die Patientin hat ja eine kardiologe Vorgeschichte.
Deswegen Alphacotoconasen.
Genau, das muss man auf alle Fälle ausschließen.
Mein Tipp ist, erstmal Danke, dass Sie sich zur Verfügung gestellt haben.
Das ist ja heute, hatten wir ein Publikum, habe ich gesehen.
Ich bedanke mich, danke.
Versuchen Sie weiter in der Systematik Konsequenz sein.
Dann vergessen Sie auch nicht die Operationen.
Das soll in Ihrem Anameseschema möglich geführt haben
und auch systematisch abarbeiten.
Die Frau Lindemann, wo ist die Operation?
Nein, nein, nein, aber Sie haben die Frau Lindemann nicht nach Operationen gefragt.
Sie haben in diesem Fall vergessen.
Aber das ist schon wichtig, das sollten Sie möglichst nicht vergessen.
Danke.
Gut.